kempen und wandern im wald sonnen am
pool und das alles nackt in diesem
naturisten camp im süden frankreichs
wissen urlauber die ruhe und vor allem
ihre nacktheit zu schätzen besonders bei
jungen leuten liegt die freikörperkultur
wieder voll im trend
die klischees fallen man gewöhnt sich an
das nacktsein das ist wie wenn man ein
bikini an hätte es ist ein bisschen
schwer sich komplett frei zu machen für
die erste stunde aber dann geht's lange
zeit waren naturisten camps einem
älteren stammpublikum vorbehalten doch
diese zeiten ändern sich
mittlerweile sind die camping und
ferienanlagen besonders bei jungen
familien mit kindern beliebt
wenn wir hier sind können wir tun was
wir wollen wir müssen keine kleidung
tragen und wir fühlen uns wohl in
unserer haut sicher ist keiner perfekt
aber das ist hier auch völlig unwichtig
und für die kinder ist es das tollste
sie lieben es seit jahren steigt die
zahl der natur lauber weltweit mit mehr
als vier millionen gästen pro jahr ist
frankreich mittlerweile das urlaubsland
nummer eins wenn es um fkk erholung geht
[Musik]